[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
[Music]
so what can you tell us about the impact
of the differences between men and women
on things like the real world stuff like
the gender pay gap for example so this
wasn't this talk wasn't recorded I
probably should record it at some point
but I gave a talk for the Adam Smith
Institute back in December and I talked
a little bit about where this kind of
wage gap comes from and I hope I get all
the details of the study right but they
were looking at people who started
scored very high on quantitative
measures like the SAT men and women who
scored very very high and they were
looking at this kind of elite
intellectual group and they asked the
men and the women in this group how many
hours a week would you work optimally if
you were you know if you had your
druthers which I don't know what
druthers are but there are things you if
you had your druthers wait how much you
know how many hours a week would you
work and I think far fewer women is like
30 or 40 percent fewer women said that
they would work more than 40 hours a
week and so if you ask women I think
this is the major difference here if you
ask women how much would you like to
work in a week and how much time would
you like to spend with your family and
how much time would you like to spend
with your kids
women say on average I would like to
spend more time with my family and my
kids
and less time working than men say that
they would like to and so that's that's
kind of a it's it's not very well
appreciated but I do think it comes down
a lot to personal preferences and men
are also more willing to kind of work on
call you know there was this study that
was done which showed that uber drivers
like men were making nine percent more
as Weber drivers than women were because
they were willing to work more when the
surge came they were willing to make
more short trips they were essentially
showing that they were more willing to
take risks and do jobs that were less
appealing another really interesting
thing about men and women in terms of
the the pay domain is that lesbians make
more than straight women do there is
something called the lesbian wage
premium lesbian privilege and lesbians
make nine percent more than what i'ma do
and you know if you were kind of going
with the kind of typical story and you
said okay well you know lesbians
obviously don't present as gender
typical they often
come across as more butch obviously I
think everybody knows that so you know
this is what this is idea like oh you
know women are assertive and they act
and I think this is true to some extent
that women who act assertive they're
called [ __ ] you know in in whatever
American black slang you say a man who
acts dominant he's bossed up whereas a
woman who acts dominant is called [ __ ]
right I do think that that happens but
you would think that a woman who didn't
act in a gender typical manner like some
lesbians do would make less money
because they would be oppressed for not
fitting in with the larger gender roles
but no they make more money and I think
it's because lesbians have some of these
characteristics like status seeking
risk-taking kind of behavior that more
feminine straight women or less likely
[Music]
you video well Jonathan pie has are what
you're talking about the gender pay gap
and it called widespread outrage I think
is the right word to use I mean incensed
on who I mean if it followed off the
back of the video we did about the Nazi
Pogue yeah which I think probably caused
more outrage it was unfortunate because
we'd written the video a few weeks
before that it just so happened that the
Polk thing happened and then we had to
release this at this time cuz it was
ready to go and it looked like we were
being deliberately provocative doing two
consecutive pieces like that but that
was the narrative actually husband isn't
it like you've gone alright like Jonna
pie is gone alright sure yeah he's
actually been criticizing the left for
ages I mean hasn't he you both I mean
you have yeah absolutely I mean if
you're familiar with the back catalogue
Jonathan pie is a lefty who bashes the
Tories more than anyone else the Tories
and Trump more than anyone else so I
mean if you you're gonna pick out these
few videos where he's I mean he does
attack the left for where the left is
going wrong because he cares about where
the left is going wrong so that makes
sense to me but the trouble is I suppose
that the videos that cause contention
are the ones that people remember or
know about and maybe they don't watch
all all of the other ones and they don't
get that that perspective perhaps so on
the gender pay gap he made a video where
Jonathan PI interviews what he thinks is
a feminist academic yeah who's releasing
a book and he's asking her expecting her
to provide the usual narrative about the
gender pay gap right and what he
encounters and very quickly gets
frustrated by is that she's more of a
second wave feminist and a third way
feminist she's not into the whole
victimhood thing that's now so popular
which is what you've been talking about
right so it's a satire in the media as
well the media have an expectation of a
certain narrative that they have to
produce and then when they're confronted
with something they're not familiar with
they don't know what to do so it's a
satirical piece yeah and what was the
response to that okay so the body some
people weren't I sort of stayed out of
this one quite a bit when when the when
people started attacking us on Twitter
but yes there was a bit of a backlash
from certain feminist groups and
certain feminist figures and comedians
more than anything I mean I didn't get
involved but I I am aware of lots of
threads that appeared on Facebook in
which I was described as an alright
anti-feminist all the rest of it because
friends might keep sending me
screenshots say look what these people
are saying about you and it's and it's
get out frenzy yeah it's odd it's odd
that a four star piece of fiction a
piece of satire can generate that kind
of response but it's also I'm up for the
debate you know if anyone wants to email
me and say why I'm wrong great and we'll
talk about it you know I'm and also what
was very interesting on all these
threads I saw all these arguments not
once did anyone present a coherent
counter-argument to any argument was
made in the video not once
it was just ad hominem it was just
you're right you're anti-feminist well
I'm not and I always called myself a
feminist always have I worry now that to
use the word means that because the word
is so currently being used to describe a
kind of victim centered feminism
whereas I believe feminism is about
equality and empowerment and unfortunate
that makes me an old-fashioned kind of
feminist but on the other hand I
shouldn't allow people to misappropriate
the word so in a sense I should hold on
to it but so that's what we were that
were in the character in that video is
as you say a feminist who hates the fact
for instance that the BBC have promoted
an app for your phone that will help
women to speak up in meetings and we
make the point that this is horribly
patronizing I mean some of my female
friends found this the most disgusting
thing but it's hailed as the BBC's this
really progressive wonderful thing I
would say the victim centered feminism
although the people who promote it or
not of course misogynists but the
premise of it is misogynist the premise
of it is that women are weaker and need
extra protection and that's why I don't
agree with it
[Music]
well the media concept of the gender
cake
the way they present it I don't think
they would ever elaborate on them that
way but the way they present is
essentially for every pound that a man
and a woman owns whatever 7718 state
that's the idea and what you're saying
is one what they're doing is essentially
they're adding up the all the earnings
of men one averaged adding up donors and
women averaging that and comparing the
two and that doesn't reflect things like
choices take time off work career
choices you know things like that right
that's definitely true but even those
statements women are earning you know X
amount of pence to the pound or the
dollar those are just false you know
that isn't that well that's essentially
implying it a question of equal pay
right you know for every pound a man
earns a woman will earn access no that's
not true
you then have to ask yourself what is
the circumstance because it could be
that for every pound of women earns who
is a CEO at a bank a man earns X
percentage less right so you know I
think that statement in and of itself is
extremely misleading if not downright
wrong so let's look at the figures in
the UK the most popular statistic used
well not necessarily most popular but
the one you'll see perhaps and you know
on the big on the big media screen this
is eighteen point four percent that is
the gender pay gap in the UK that
statistics calculated by the Office of
National Statistics which is a really
good job of calculating the pay gap but
that combines full-time workers and
part-time workers we know that women are
significantly more likely to work
part-time and that those jobs tend to
pay less so I think in and of itself
that is a really unfair calculation
you're not comparing like for like if
you just separate part-time workers from
full-time workers that's all you've done
you still have not taken into account
age job background children anything you
get nine point one percent pay gap for
full-time workers negative five point
one percent pay gap for part-time
workers so that's a pay gap in favor of
women so part-time workers for a female
actually out earn their male counterpart
yes exactly so just by doing that one
thing you've cut the pay gap in half for
full-time and you've actually shown that
women are
doing better on average and part-time
work so that just goes to show how how
manipulated these statistics statistics
can be when you just are taking one
thing into account then when you start
to go into age start to go into
background you know the pay gap gets
smaller and smaller and smaller so in
the UK women between the ages of 22 to
39 are basically earning the same as men
the pay gap is negligible in 2015 women
aged 22 to 29 were earning slightly more
a tiny percentage right now men are
earning 2% 2.5 percent more that's a
negligible statistics so you know we can
actually say that the gender pay gap has
been eradicated for men and women
between the ages of 20 and 40 that's a
huge part of your working life you know
that's absolutely fantastic I think the
pay gap that still exists after that age
has a lot to do with maternity leave and
the fact that women take years off work
on average compared to men it has to do
with a lot of choices that women are
making in terms of jobs and work culture
and what they value it has a lot to do
with whether or not you're willing to
work overtime willing to work weekends
that feeds into job culture and all that
and none of those things are in job the
actual job that you choose to do none of
those things are calculated in the pay
gap so even the very basic statistics we
have showing a pretty good picture for
women the pay gaps the lowest it's ever
been on record since I started
calculating it in the UK and you know
that hasn't taken into account very
important things so if that's the case
and you're saying that it's negligible
don't why are we constantly getting
bombarded with these facts and
statistics about how women are being our
earned by men we live in an unfair
society we live in a sexist society why
why are we getting that story well I
have two theories one's generous and one
isn't which one which one you want first
let's go both I think the generous one
is that it's 2018 it's an important year
it's a hundred women 100 women it's a
hundred hundred years since women got
the vote in the UK and something still
doesn't feel quite right you know as a
woman in 2018
you still recognize that a lot of the
cards are stacked against you you know
look at de viola look at domestic
violence tats look at rape statistics
compare men and women walking home alone
on any given evening you know women have
their car keys in their in their fingers
and men don't something still doesn't
feel right it doesn't seem fair and I
think that that very legitimate feeling
that we can all pretty much agree on
then people want to harness that and say
well what are we gonna do about it
and unfortunately people go to the
gender pay gap because I think it's
something that they can really easily
solve through legislation I think well I
want to see results I want to get a law
passed I want to get something done
let's focus on the gender pay gap
because we can make the state make big
business publish their pay gap figures
you know we can do something and say we
got a win we got a policy win but of
course that that has no meaningful
impact on the things that I think women
are still actually facing and the
disadvantages that we have in society so
I mean that would be my generous reading
of it that people just want to do
something about the unfairness that they
still see in the world
so they latch on to the pay gap even
though that's not where we need to be
latching on to if anything we can say
this seems to be going extremely well
there's still some things we could do to
help women who work for sure but this is
not the major area we need to look at
violence we need to look at your all's
wood Detention Center where immigrant
women are kept and detained and treated
horribly you know that's what we need to
look at my last generous reading is that
you know it's a lucrative and popular
business to be promoting victimhood
culture and the larger the statistic the
more media attention you'll get you know
if you look at a lot of these articles
across the spectrum it's no particular
publication you know if easyJet was a
really good example when businesses had
to publish their pay gap figures for the
first time back in April
you know every headline was easyJet has
52 percent gender pay gap massive and
you had to get to article 6 oh sorry
paragraph 6 or 7 if it was in the
article at all where it said action
the reason that they have this pay gap
is that they pay their pilots a hundred
a year they pay the stewards 25 grand a
year
they 6% of their pilots are women ninety
four percent are men this is double the
worldwide average of female pilots
they're actually doing really well they
can't hire more female pilots because
they don't exist they implemented a
program years back with their own
profits off their own back to bring in
more women by 2020 this is a company
that is doing everything it can to
encourage women support women and to pay
them fairly and equally and this is the
reason for their pay gap but that was
not at the top of the article that was
if you're lucky at the bottom and so
those big statistics sell I think
there's a real effort right now to press
the reset button on the gender pay gap
it really wasn't that long ago you know
forty years ago where you could see a
genuine pay gap that was based on
discrimination that women got paid less
than men and that has closed so
dramatically for a lot of reasons
including the fact that women are
getting better educated they're more
educated than men on average and they're
going on to do those top jobs you know
they're extremely motivated there isn't
that glass ceiling anymore and you know
that pay gap has been shrinking and
shrinking and shrinking which is great
news it's a wonderful story to tell
especially young women and a lot of
these groups that do very well
perpetuating that victimhood mentality
need to press a reset button they need
to be able to say that something's still
wrong here in order to have relevance
and they've been really successful I
mean up until April the pay gap the
biggest one you could come up with was
eighteen point four percent but that's
quite misleading you know we've got this
great story about nine point one percent
negative five point one percent and then
they get these big businesses without
much context at all to publish their pay
gap statistics and now they can say 52
percent gender pay gap 70 percent gender
pay gap it's as if you know the past 50
years didn't exist and that's great for
them it's a really bad message for
normal women they were just going to
work in the morning pouring a cup of
coffee now thinking to themselves if I
work for easy chat are they
discriminating against me no they want
to perpetuate you they want to bring you
up they want to propel you to top spots
actually
but if you just read the headline a lot
of people do you're gonna have a pretty
negative attitude so that's my slightly
more skeptical perspective I think
they're trying to push the reset button
to make this issue still relevant I
think it's really terrible for young
women especially to see this so the
gender pay gap I think is a really
really good example of how statistics
can be used to prove anything that you
want them to prove at all because it all
depends on what we measure so if you
want to make the gender pay gap seem
massive then what you do is you look at
the earnings of all men and the earnings
of all women and you compare them with
each other and surprise surprise you
find out that women earn less than men
but obviously what that's not taking
into account is the hours that men and
women work the jobs that men and women
do and this fact that we've already
mentioned you know in the past men and
women weren't as equal as they are today
so if you look at the top rungs of
careers where people have been working
for 30 40 years they've reached the
absolute top of their profession you are
more likely to find men in those
positions so if you do that you take all
men's wages all women's wages you find a
very very big gender pay gap but
basically the more we compare like for
like so the more you look at men and
women doing the same jobs for the same
number of hours for the same level of
experience then the pay gap gets
narrower and narrower and narrower and
eventually comparing like for like it
disappears altogether there's no gender
pay gap if you look at men and women who
are both doing the same job same length
of time same number of hours each week
and of course that's the case I mean you
just think about this for like a minute
or two because for one thing it's
illegal so if you took two people who
are doing the exact same job exact same
hours exact same level and the man was
being paid more the woman could take
this company the bossed court you know
it would be illegal they would be
breaking the law but but there's an even
more common-sense argument as well if if
bosses
get away with paying women substantially
less for doing the exact same workers as
men do but but just cheaper you know why
would any boss anywhere ever employ a
man you know why would you get a man to
do the job well it's interesting that
you say that because we're recording
this and by the time this goes out it
will be a couple of weeks from today
probably the guest who's episode we've
just released is a lady called dr.
Pittman Mangrum who's a good friend and
a wonderful person she's a former
adviser to an American president founder
of her own company etc and when we
talked to her we asked her about the pay
gap as well and she said that as a
speaker after her political career and
all the rest of it she actually had her
own agent speaking agent say to her your
metrics are grey you're getting better
performances than your male counterparts
but we cannot get you the same fees
because you're a woman so there is there
is some I mean not everyone is rational
not everyone I mean you say it's illegal
and it is but people do illegal stuff
all the time right so there's probably a
small element of the discrimination that
is part of what causes the gender pay
gap but I totally hear your argument
about these averages being useless
essentially and measuring the real
gender pay gap but I so my question you
think there's no discrimination against
women all in a way I mean I I don't know
the woman who you've you've just
interviewed numb really looking forward
to watch that interview with great
interest but I mean some possible advice
from me to her you know and I'm sure
she's really probably won't watch and
won't appreciate this but if I was her
I'd say she's not anyone she's not
someone who would whine or complain she
took action I sacked that agent get
yourself my point is she's a very very
accomplished very powerful person who's
who's made great success of her life not
every person is I'm not as accomplished
or successful and I'm you know so
they're not everyone is capable of
necessarily of that not everyone is in a
position where their values so high then
they can do that definitely well I think
there's a couple of things to say here I
mean for one thing I think that
when we compare Mesa we hear on the news
you know about bp's women who work at
the BBC being paid a lot less than men's
that there was even a story about
martina navratilova when she was doing
the commentary at the Liddy Wimbledon
the tennis being paid less than I can be
on board no Mac and rode John McEnroe
doing likewise doing the coverage of
Wimbledon but then you stop and you look
at this you know McEnroe is a much
bigger personality he was the one who
was fronting the BBC's coverage he was
doing ten times as much lot of the live
broadcasts as Navratilova was so again
you just were not comparing
like-for-like and the way the story
appears is like oh poor martina
navratilova isn't it terrible
Orvis discrimination so we had know the
story about Claire Foy and Matt Smith in
the crown you know Claire Foy was being
paid less than Matt Smith isn't this
terrible she was in the lead role at
cetera et cetera
apart from before the crown who had
heard of Claire Foy you know not me
whereas Matt Smith had been Doctor Who
so when we talk about speakers
celebrities sports stars their salaries
are not worked out in the same way age I
mean if you are working in McDonald's
and you say oh you know actually I'd
like to negotiate for pay raise yeah
good luck with that they show you the
door this is not to say that I don't
think there's any truth in what you're
saying I do think that there's a perhaps
a confidence issue for women where they
are less likely to push themselves
forward perhaps undervalue themselves
you know I've certainly been in cases
particularly when I speak up American
universities and they'll ask me well
what's your going rate oh my god I have
no idea how to answer this question and
the fear is if you know my fear is you
pitch yourself too high they're gonna
say no thank you and laugh and you end
up underselling myself as a result but
you know what I think feminism today age
doesn't help women with that confidence
problem I think the more we hear it's so
[ __ ] being a woman it's so awful the
more you do then begin to undervalue
yourself you you think then when people
undervalue you you think oh yes this is
just what life's like for being a woman
because it's really awful and terrible
so I think the best thing feminism could
do for women would be to say actually
there's loads of opportunities out there
never been a better time to be a woman
get out there take advantage of all
these opportunities don't sit at home
under selling yourself if you enjoyed
this week as always follow us on trigger
at trigger pod on Twitter Instagram
where on Facebook as well I'm Constance
in kissing you can find me on Twitter to
add Constance and Kissin failing human
but mostly people just do it if you've
enjoyed it please give us a rating five
stars say something nice tell a friend
about it we are on iTunes we are on
what's new on the pocket one pocket cast
I think is it pocket cost blankly
subscribe to our YouTube channel we're
building up audio our audience and we'll
be back next week with another so thanks
very much I need top you going for next
week right c7 thanks bye